メイザーエアバスですかなんでこんな自由にある空気彫ってあるじゃないですかあれば
米アポインター月のねらいのまとを定めて打てる空気法です
うわぁ凄いだでも本気じゃんでこれもスタンドスタンドスタンドつい釣ってるじゃん
まあ違うこうやって打つのかあって怖い怖い怖い本当に凝る人知らないかなかつたん
ですよおり頃やって家でおり紅ヤンキーが使う
9時4だからもう多分殺傷力はマジでヤバいと思いますで僕空気法好きなんですよあ
などで探してたら明らかに異常な値段で売ってましたこの空気法
そういう意味では
影響を受けてねー
[音楽]
空気法なって立富2段ボールとかで作れますからね言葉でもうこりゃボブで作りが開い
階程度仲間してヤバそうな空港なんでレーザーポインター月でしょ
完全に
持ってくれればまずでこれ強そうなんですって組み立ててみますはそもそも組み立て方
がわからないも絶命し多いそしてペッパーってねっ
めっちゃあるんだけど今って空気打つだけじゃないのでマッシュ
たしてわかんないなんか難しいなきゃ人を殺めることもできる空気法が違うレベルが
まじかこれすっげー難しいなきためウエディングヒルズへまだもう
分でオズつけちゃいました分でこれちょっとはじめムズムズ真面目末待ってとって本当
に難しい
以外てメポぐりぽん
ています
[音楽]
ん
無理だよ
ああああああああ
伝えたいたいたい本当にハイんだまず
を負った
こんな時でもお菓子は人の気持ちを落ち着かせるのです
ニーダムだってこれまた物理的に厳しくなりません
ねえだろどう考えとつかないよ俺てーっ
今何か言った気がしたブーツワーキター
あーうーうーうーを後は余裕だわたぶんめっちゃ硬かったり本当に大丈夫
どこまで本気屋根ものたてく所言うこれでひとまず見た目は関西じゃないでしょうか
あったベンチを入れたらレーザーポインターが出ます
まーすっと立ってすごいなこれずいぶん塗ってみます
持っていた
周囲結構やばくないはっはっは
ブービー賞って言っ
レーザーロサタブ内
すとろ実はにありますよねはいとだけでレーザーポインター月もう完全にトンビをさせ
に入っているこちらの空気法でもうちょっとたまたま来てる玉池友達やの脳天を
撃ち抜いてやろうと思います
いやーこれ本当威力すごいからねおっとっと破裂音ですけどあそこなガンベル狙って
みますぅヤフーの狙いを定めて浮きます
こら入っているで完全に破格の威力を持っておりますこちら
早速名前けど友達は打ってほしいこと思いますよ行こう
[音楽]
はっはっは
おや言え何度言ったそういうえちゃんとホントそういうのがないん
[音楽]
ふーん4マリーウィンド
事例4
んさーあああっ必須ん
[音楽]
me
teame
nara
me
me あった